[Music]
you know this is the time of year of
spring and summer is looming and
barbecues and swimming pools and all
sorts of positivity so we take a break
from that and we give you the 12 worst
franchises in the national football
league there was no formula here there
are no analytics involved this is a
qualitative gut feeling based upon
present and past to the extent of the
justified placement on the list but we
begin
and i should run through all 12 of the
dirty dozen since the radio audience
can't see the graphic
cardinals at number one which means they
are number 32. we get the chris you
understand how that works
if you're the top of the dirty does that
means you're the worst so we go
cardinals at number one let me just get
your reaction on that before we continue
down the list yeah i i agree with that
that's where i would put them right now
too i think that if i had a rank or
power rank football teams i'd put the
cardinals at the bottom of football
right now a lot of questions coaches
players roster wasn't that good last
year so i'm not going to disagree with
you there
and they're going to be underdogs in
every game this year going into the
season it was a pickham proposition
before patrick peterson was suspended
for six games so they likely will be
underdogs at home against the detroit
lions when the season begins and they
will be underdogs in all their games as
the season begins now look they could
prove us wrong but they need kyler
murray to have
a patrick mahomes baker mayfield type of
an impact or this team is going to be at
32
when the 2019 season ends all right
number two at number three a new york
city monopoly jets two giants three
could have gone giants two jets three
but you know with the just there's so
much dysfunction with adjustment i
actually think the jets are gonna be
decent this year but you can't ignore 50
years of futility you can't ignore the
chronic inability to get a franchise
quarterback and you can't ignore this
inability by ownership to just
understand how to how to manage a
football team you don't fire your gm
four months after you fire your coach
get rid of everybody at the same time
get a gm in there let the gm hire the
coach get everybody on the same page and
move forward and they're gonna have a
hard time getting everybody on the same
page as they look for a gm now because
unless it's adam gases hand-picked gm
the new gm is gonna want his own coach
sooner rather than later well yeah okay
i mean i'm not going to totally go
ham on them for the way they handle the
gm situation i know in the perfect world
yeah you'd like to start a new regime
off with a new gm and a new head coach
all together but it's not the worst
thing in the world what they did and how
they handled the mccagne situation i
actually probably am surprised by this
more than any i mean you just said you
think the jets are going to be a pretty
good football team you talked about they
franchise quarterback well they got the
franchise quarterback so to me this is a
little low for the new york jets i mean
i certainly wouldn't have put them below
the giants or the dolphins or the
bengals for that matter those teams
alone i think are uh in worse spots than
the new york jets are right now so that
was probably one of the shockers of your
dirty dozen to me
it just feels like the jets are the
personification of murphy's law and
everything that can go wrong does go
wrong for the jets and every time it
feels like they're they're beginning to
break free from the muck it just falls
apart that there's always something that
happens to the jets and i'm factoring
that in going forward that as as jets
fans and i think i think seasoned jets
fans know not to get excited about what
could happen this year because every
time you begin to allow yourself to get
excited if you're a jets fan that's when
the bottom falls out and i feel like i
feel like what happened last week is
just that reminder that the bottom can
and will fall out for the new york jets
what do you think about the giants at
three well i i mean i don't i can't
disagree with you there i would think
the giants at three i would probably
have them switched with the dolphins i
would look at i still think the giants
are in a better spot organizationally
than the miami dolphins at this point i
know it hasn't been a great offseason
and all that but you know there is
certain things to still like on the
giants roster you know uh they do have
eli manning who's at least played there
i mean got experience we know he can
play in some big games it's not overly
talented but i guess i guess it's a
close call there between giants and
dolphins but i would give them the edge
over the dolphins as far as being a
little bit better of a football team and
a totality organization at this point
right now
well i mean they have won super bowls in
the last 45 years which would give the
gelatin edge over the dolphins that way
and the thing about the dolphins i mean
it has been 20 years since dan marino
they have been careening around
aimlessly at the quarterback position
they could have had drew brees they took
dante culpepper and his wrecked knee
instead and gave the vikings a second
round pick for culpepper when drew brees
was free and clear available in free
agency and it just feels like they can't
find that quarterback and i feel like if
they could find that quarterback and
develop that quarterback that they could
become relevant again i think that's one
of the reasons why they hung on to ryan
tannehill as long as they did because
they had themselves convinced they had
finally found a new dan marino and they
were going to give him every chance
possible to become dan marino and once
it finally became clear after seven
seasons it wasn't happening they move on
but uh i i you know the the doll and the
dolphins are another time i feel like
that you know so many of these bad teams
it's just one move here one move there
and some prudence by ownership you know
my biggest problem with the dolphins is
this the owner doesn't live in south
florida and i think if you really want
to have an impact on a team you need to
be in the building every day that's how
you avoid dysfunction because when the
owner isn't there then you have other
people who set up their little fiefdoms
and you have these internal power
struggles and people lose sight of what
the shared objective is if the owner's
there every day that crap doesn't happen
and that's why i think that anybody you
know the dolphins fans would be better
off frankly if steven ross either moved
to miami and showed up every day or sold
the team to someone who would yeah i i
agree with you 100 there i mean
ownership having that leadership in the
building on a daily basis you know
having everybody on edge walking on a
shell eggshells a little bit you know
the accountability factor it's needed as
far as an nfl organization and and if
you want it at its absolute best i mean
you can look at the teams that are
successful in the nfl and i think more
times than not you're going to look at
it and go oh ownership is very relevant
in the building on a daily basis you
know and of course we can always start
that conversation off with the new
england patriots and the kraft family
you know if robert craft isn't in the
building looking over things jonathan
craft is certainly there you know but
again i just think if you look at the
the successful organizations whether
that's the the eagles uh and what
they've done here recently and the other
teams that continue to kind of stay at
the top on a yearly basis it is good
leadership and the ownership is involved
and at least in the building to keep
everybody crossing their tees and
dotting their eyes on a daily basis yeah
even if you only spend 20 of your time
on the football team if you've got
broader business interests like the
crafts do like other owners do you still
show you have to work somewhere right
show up there do your work there the
other people don't realize you're not
working on the football team you are
there you are present there is a
tangible value to being present that's
one of the reasons why the dolphins are
present at number four on the list i
don't know maybe they should be higher
than four all right rest of the list
bengals five yeah raiders six
washington seven
bucks at eight they would be much higher
on that list if they didn't have bruce
arians and head coach lions at nine
broncos 10 49ers 11 brown's 12. what's
the biggest thing that stands out you
know i mean i guess the the the biggest
thing that stands out to me like the
49ers and browns i look at those as
teams as being like borderline certainly
could have been off this list right like
which is why they're at 11 and 12. i get
you i understand i'm just framing it
there so to me that's i just who were
you nitpicking with there because like i
think right now if i had to do the off
season and do my dirty dozen i'd
probably have the tennessee titans on
there for at least a substitute for the
browns or the or or the 49ers one of
those two teams that i'm just interested
to hear who you were kind of battling it
out with for those teams uh that were
outside the the dirty dozen
well i mean for the browns look here's
the thing a year ago they would have
been the clear number one and they
wouldn't have been a number two right
yeah because they were they were 1 in 31
after two seasons the fact that they
would go from 1 to 12 in one year is
amazing and they still haven't done
anything i mean i'm taking freddie
kitchen's
mantra to heart we haven't won anything
yet that's right you haven't now there's
a lot of reason to think that they will
and they've got great players but freddy
kitchens is unproven he's got to prove
that he can coach and the thing that
concerns me about the browns all due
respect which means here comes the
insult ownership meddles too much
ownership causes too many problems with
the browns and i think that this team if
it thrives it's going to thrive in spite
of ownership not because of ownership
and i think that's one of the reasons
why they're still on the list they could
break free from it easily this year but
they're the ones who can do it you know
i all that pressure all those
expectations i keep looking at the first
two weeks you mentioned the titans they
have tennessee and they have the jets
the first two weeks right they come out
of that one and one or o and two they
come out at 0-2 and the sky is going to
be falling in cleveland we'll see how
they deal with that adversity i believe
in that guy though baker mayfield that
he's going to turn this team around and
they will be off this list next year if
we remember to do it next year and and i
i think that he as long as they just let
build it around him don't let him
overtake the team that's the balance you
want to build it around him but don't
let him overtake the team and become a
lebron james type of a figure in
cleveland you still want him to operate
within the confines of a broader team
yeah i think he'll do that i think he's
a team guy first anyways i really would
be shocked if the dna of baker mayfield
changes i i really think he has it or
whatever it is the magic about him the
charismatic way about him uh to league
and organization and hey i'll say this
if i had a bet right now i'm gonna bet
cleveland makes it into the playoffs
this year i think they're that talented
i do have enough faith in freddie
kitchen's their offensive line their run
game what they do on the defensive side
of the ball
i like that steve wilkes is the d
coordinator there i think that's
actually an upgrade i mean some of the
the moves they talked made in free
agency you know again i do think
ownership seems to be out of the way a
little bit to your point what you're
saying ever since john dorsey has taken
over i feel like it's kind of been his
thumbprint uh on everything or
fingerprint i should say on everything
to this point as far as football is
concerned and i find that encouraging
for the browns too
you know the team that i thought about
putting on there you mentioned the
titans i actually flirted with the
texans and the fact they've only been
around 17 years helped them stay off of
it because you know it took them a long
time to get to the playoffs and it seems
like when they get to the playoffs they
just they
they disappoint in dramatic fashion they
just don't show up for so many of these
post-season games they get that 4 30 p.m
eastern slot on a saturday afternoon and
they end up just just looking awful it's
like at some point you've got to do
something more than that to be
considered in the top half of the league
but they're in that that's going to
change
they had crap quarterbacks and not guys
that were going to lead them in those
big moments
they lost it they lost it home to the
colts last year in the postseason thank
you captain which was a surprise yeah
but what i'm saying is i got to sean
watson i'm you know if he's going to get
sacked 65 times a year he's not going to
be uh healthy enough to help turn the
team around all right we're going to
take a break when we return deshawn
watson could be the nfl mvp this year
plenty of others could as well we'll
show you some of the fanduel mvp odds
and we'll talk about which ones we like
when pft live continues right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports